بكره يا خرطومه تعودي بهذه الكلمات
المؤثره ابكى طيار سوداني يدعى مهند سلامه
ركاب الطائره اثناء الهبوط في مطار
بورسيدان الدولي كما اثارت القصيده التي
القاها على الركاب تفاعلا واسعا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
نتمنى
في مدينه السلام
تعرضت الفنانه العالميه
لموقف محرج اثناء عرضها الاخير في شيكاغو
حيث ابتلعت حشره بالخطا على المسرح ماذا
فعلها ما دفعها للتوقف عن الغناء نشاهد
كيف كانت ردته فعلها
[تصفيق]
حاله من الجدل اثارتها شركه هنديه بعد
انتشار مقطع فيديو لاحد موظفي الامن وهو
يغلق الباب الرئيسي لمنع خروج الموظفين
اثناء وقت العمل وذلك بتعليمات من المدير
مقطع الفيديو المنتشر اثارا غضبا واسعا
بين رواد مواقع التواصل
[موسيقى]
الاجتماعي بمقاطع فيديو متداوله توثقه
لحظه انهيار جسر معلق
معلق عملاق وسقوطه في نهر بالهند للمره
الثانيه خلال عام بلغت تكلفه تشييد الجسر
حوالي
280 دولار ما اثار غضبا واسعا لدى سكان
المنطقه بسبب سوء اداره المشروع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات